little trees there a rearview mirror
staple protecting noses from offensive
odors all over the world but where do
they come from over sixty years ago a
scientist by the name of Julius Amon had
a chance encounter with a milkman that
changed the course of the air freshener
game forever it was in Watertown New
York a milkman was making the rounds
when he stopped to speak to Julius a
German Jewish chemist who fled the Nazis
and studied out buying tree aromas in
the forests of Canada said milkman began
venting to Julius about the stench that
spoiled milk left in his car and thus
the quest began to destroy bad car odors
Julius drew inspiration from the tree
aromas he studied by infusing their oils
onto paper in 1954 he filed a patent for
tree shaped paper infused with odor
destroying air perfume
Julius then started producing the air
fresheners out of an empty auto shop and
sending samples to local gas stations
the little trees were a big hit and
Julius successfully created the first
automotive air freshener though the look
remains the same the scents are forever
changing now the little tree company has
over 60 cents and has sold over a
billion little trees worldwide